remember that time Aunt May died but not
really yeah sure it helped I paused for
a second so I can make sure that I
wouldn't lose me progress with my files
got corrupted again because boy has that
happen a lot what was I talking about
what are my thoughts on the ultimate
animated series it's not spectacular
I'll say that I'll say that interpret
that how you will
are you okay my head is killing me
pounding so hard I think it's my
spider-sense thing and going Gus you you
might need to get somewhere safe
such a cool shot Eddie oh my god you I
thought my head killing me what's going
on oh my head so I guess in this
universe proximity was venom makes this
better sense go crazy instead of does
not work at all you can get in a pretty
good combo and kick a little token
priority excuse me Eddie I need to get
that so by nature of this fight the fact
is like you can't get costume for too
long without the spider fencing like
making me freak out so I like all
Tesla's to demonstrate well I didn't
want that to happen I think it's so cool
that his how far regenerates for
everything that is Boston
Wow there you go so spider-sense gives
them a headache and you kind of like
opens you up for a free hit from venom
so the the key method is to just lame it
out but I don't like doing that you
could really just do this fight entirely
by jumping around them in a circle and
then just just jumping down on his head
like this well what happens when you
when you try to hotdog kid you get ya
jetty cut down for your arrogance Oh God
here let's try webbing him up because
that'll work have at you cool feeling oh
[ __ ] he'll fit for that other better
universe to suit to get make its own way
know what the decision was that led
Bendis ticket thing yeah mark if you
could off you can just draw Eddie
brought to look like mmm vows afraid but
put add some freckles so he doesn't look
exactly like him but
fill up pretty much exactly like jump
jump jump okay there we go
hahaha I'm normally a lot better at this
fight but I want it to be interesting
visually so I'm going to fight him and
see I'll put us on even ground instead
of just claiming it out like a cross
cutting where you just jump around and
and then bounce on his head the added
Mario sound effects this would be great
[Music]
you know Konami
all down okay all right oh I I got in a
lot of hit I got really lucky there I
like how his health doesn't go all the
way down don't make me hurt you ready
I'm totally serious
[Music]
brach
you guys are shield you're in the way
[Music]
[Music]
then go down prep for evac
Hey
what is this what's going on nothing
that concerns you my food rig thank you
sure I'll just stay here I think it's
cool that you actually start the the
gameplay where the cutscene ended so
should I get back to that like field
trip at the Museum and hanging out of NJ
or nob just nod socket she understands
well we have an agreement it's that I am
totally allowed to just abandon her at
any random interval and then argue that
I was saving someone or something when
she goes where have you been all night
and why do you smell like alcohol and
I'll go I just had to had to save a
bunch of people of that brewery in lmj
actually nice think about it alcoholics
spider-man could be a really funny and
or sad storyline
hey Dan Slott if you're not too busy
like you know ruining [ __ ] maybe maybe
that could be an idea for you I'm joking
don't actually do that there be awful
boo token is that a costume token can I
actually get any of that [ __ ] now or
characters concept art caustic costumes
all right what do we got here a whole
lotta nothin alright thanks great that
was that was completely worth my time
thank you Jesus where does a guy have to
do to dress up like black suit
spider-man around here
Oh a just play any game except this one
I like how casual the music was
considering what just happened hey you
know what else is funny or about that
scene in the comic version where where
they you know silver sable and our guys
just come and pick up Eddie is that they
take him in like a white van instead of
like a Helicarrier thing they just load
them into the back of a van and take off
and he's completely naked and it looks
so shady and it makes me question my
spider-man didn't immediately assume
that they were not on the up-and-up
all right well see ya you okay or oh no
they hurt your wrist slightly sir final
gate hostile your freeloader
I feel like just think this guy actually
has some kind of unrelated medical issue
that he needed like this guy's wrist was
hurt from something else so you had bad
health insurance what's it
yeah the dialogue in the background is
strange like here's some people say some
weird stuff what are City goals sitter
sitter goals no city goals Oh God
I might just like
because this one has the least amount of
busywork except for like web of shadows
where that game basically is just like
alright here's the story all right
here's more of the story alright here's
the rest of the story so this one they
make it and make it work for it a little
because this came out immediately after
spider-man 2 and it was customary at the
time and then and then later games he
just had no reason at all to do anything
in the open world like the amazing
spider-man games could absolutely not
have been open-world at all and none of
the experience was been lost because
those games like like almost nothing hat
but really the open world is just a hub
that lets let you get from one person to
the next
oh man the military gang and the kungfu
gang or fighting leave it to New York ah
tried to jump over and web this guy up
take this guy who Begley looks like
shang-chi is that racist I don't know
probably
hey I started on I'm actually Russian I
was a little weird
my grandma decided to go check one of
those ancestry websites and found out
that her dad wasn't from Germany like
they thought he was he was actually born
from two Siberian parents like it was I
was fine with it in fact I was kind of
excited because that's like a that's a
neat thing to learn about yourself and
then I immediately went to go to call my
dad and he is just so defeated because
he's always been really proud of his
German heritage even if I got the
rosetta stone to learn the language and
he's always talking about places in the
country he'd like to go visit and now to
find out that he's not german at all and
is actually siberian jurist
wow it's been rough stunning revelation
okay Larry there's another way wait I
think I have the amount of City event
well uh sorry Uncle Ben I guess I'll
just be going to get more race medals
that uh that crime can solve itself no I
don't want to keep that I bet most of
this episode will be me doing side
mission boxes instead of stories few
more questions on here what did I think
in a homecoming favor I think it looks
pretty good
but I've had my heart broken in the past
and I'm I'm I'm having a hard time
learning how to love again you know like
I want the movie to be the best ever and
there's always going to be this nagging
part of my brain going out so I'd be
okay at that so you know I hope I'm
wrong um I actually have a lot to say on
the homecoming trailer other than that
like I'd be willing to do a whole video
about it if people were actually
interested like you wanted to hear my
thoughts on it like I wrote a script for
it to like it's like three pages long of
just like talking about the trailer but
then like I I don't know I waited a
really long time to write it until like
after the trailer came out because I
want to make sure it wasn't like wasn't
one of those hype things where you're
just saying yeah it looks great because
I thought five minutes ago I wanted to
actually like really take it in and
digest what I looked at Wow his
Manhattan full of nothing but these had
always bloom out okay where all the
races the hell you know it'd be really
helpful if you could set up like a
waypoint alright I guess I'm hauling my
ass back to Queens
since all the races seem to be over
there and everything over here is just
combat tours so yeah if you'd like to
see me do a whole analysis of the
homecoming trailer I I'd be willing to
give it a shot but you know otherwise
I know it's been it's been so long that
it it'd be kind of kind of pointless now
because it's not like like bugs worthy
like what why are you talking about the
trailer three months after it came out
just cuz that seems to be a good reason
to do a lot of things in life just cuz I
think this is the smokestack where Peter
dropped both carnage and the first dose
of the symbiote that he gets he seems to
solve a lot of his problem so I just
taking it to a smokestack and then just
dropping it in there
he did that with Ben Reilly in the other
universe and then he tried to kill both
symbiote
well technically symbiotes with it there
we go there's a race which one do I want
to I know the hospital one is kind of
easy let's go do that one dun dun dun
dun dun dent dent you know that's how
the song goes
Jamie I could all right well yeah yeah
there it is
this one I think I can do okay what
wasn't expecting it to be down there
what all right
oh come on really I hit the edges of
this object that's really just more of
in my imagination like oh boy as clearly
i dunk that one up goal of metal are you
serious how
alright watch I'm not going to say no to
that [ __ ] all right cool
okay back to swinging around and
spending like I know what I'm talking
about what do I think of one more day
I think everyone who's currently still
enforcing one more day is an egocentric
[ __ ] like that tweet I saw where
someone said nobody likes one more day I
think it was like one of the head guys
at Marvel and then they replied with the
medicine may not pick it tastes well but
you have to take it anyway implying that
one more day needs to happen this suit
huh it was made by our fathers but it
used my dad's DNA starting out so it's
like heart you know well yeah
in a crazy way when I got close to it in
a museum it felt like my brain was going
to crawl out of my face
ill ah ill again sorry do you know what
you're doing
kind of
what is it I have no idea what is this
laughing I have no idea part are you
serious I did all that just to get a
two-second cutscene you couldn't have
just swung straight home all right ball
all right
I love this game but I just want to
fight electro or punch Rhino was there
whatever I want to I want to keep having
to do races Oh God ah
yeah I'm gonna just grind out all the
side missions like I'm gonna do like
beat combat tours because the game in
the brass you do do that many um well
last question sir well actually still I
have a few more things to say about one
more day so I don't blame J michael
Straczynski the guy who wrote one more
day because I like he basically had a
gun and put to his head to write it
because it was the editorial staff of
Marvel were like hey we need to make
some changes around here we don't like
that Peter Parker's identity is known to
people and we don't like that he is like
a married family man and stuff like undo
10 years of character development why
don't you have him living in Aunt May's
basement or whatever and J michael
Straczynski I I think all of my favorite
spider-man stories from the last 20
years were written by JMS because I love
pretty much everything from the 70s and
80s and then the 90s or when you're like
oh this is and then you get to the jmx
stuff in the 2000s all the way up until
like Civil War and that's all great and
then and then one more day just kind of
ushered in a long period of just like
stories that are like alright that one
was okay
like I thought American Sun was cool I
guess you know we're we're normalized
one gives Harry a robot suit
and and runs an evil Avengers that one
was ok hey I have a controversial
opinion I think Dan Slott stories are
kind of a not obnoxious and stupid
and I'm getting really really tired of
him because he's been writing the book
for like I think it's been about ten
years I really think it's stagnated like
some of his earlier stuff was okay some
of his earlier stuff was even flat-out
cool but then when you get to like the
more recent stuff where he keeps trying
to shove clones in our face and then you
know kill characters just to have it on
not immediately or our character
development is just like also a lot of
character development gets undone by Dan
Slott like everything just suddenly kind
of becomes pointless like people act
horribly out of character for no reason
or things that were established in made
sense at a certain point just like he
completely changes the rules of them I'm
really not happy with how the alter how
the amazing spider-man stories are going
right now because let me ask you a
question when you think about spider-man
what do you what do you like about him
it can't just be because of the costume
and the powers Peter Parker is
interesting yeah I know Peter Parker is
interesting because he's relatable and
he has realized problems and he's a
normal person like everybody at one
point or another has faced a situation
that Peter Parker is face whether it be
like I can't pay rent or I've missed too
much school and now my grades are
starting to follow the [ __ ] or oh man I
really bombed that test I wish I could
do better next time or or people at
school are nice like you know trying to
turn up some stuff that nerds him and
happen to deal with and then one day for
him to just like wake up and be Bill
Gates it's just I don't know if not
relate like people always reference
spider-man's positives are that he's not
Bruce Wayne and he's not Tony Stark he
doesn't have all that
money and for him to suddenly have all
that money kind of undermines all that
because now like his problems they're
like oh no I got mustard on my tie
before a big press conference where I
mean unveiling a new brand of technology
from my multi-billion dollar company
what uh no no you know I hope the audio
didn't glitch out because I've been
recording for 20 minutes 21 minutes now
but you know what I mean like I feel
free to disagree with me but that's just
my feelings on the subject so I kind of
want a new writer for spider-man ooh
finally city events have been swinging
around in circles for like 10 minutes
looking for where you love things where
you at Dawg hey how you doing
since our packs let's plays are cheap
and easy